a focus group of undecided voters in
Telford early voting marginal hotly
contested by conservatives and labour
this seat and others like it will decide
the results of this election
I'm here with Gerry latter from you Gulf
so Gerry you picked the group for us
who's in it and why did you pick them so
we picked 10 voters in the constituency
of Telford who haven't yet completely
decided who they're going to vote for at
the election okay
well let's have a listen to what they
said I think you started often you on
how is the campaign going what did they
have to say I think the main theme is
lies lies and sound bites and stuff that
sounds good when it offers stuff they're
supposed to sound good when it hits your
ear performance they're more worried
about their performance rather than the
substance of what they're saying that
the truth for talking policies it just
seems like show time isn't it popularity
contest and like you say one play one
off the other and just become a little
bit of the fast as if they don't care
about the tell us all this we're going
to do this we're going to do that and
they'll get elected and they're like I
didn't say that what you did because
we've got I didn't say that we meant
something else are you glad we're in an
election at the moment do you feel
enthused by it I think I know the answer
this enthusiastic about there being a
new government no not at this time maybe
a rec initiative postpone this until
after Christmas
it's just put like a blanket over things
that's a niche but did he feel
frustrated by the Parliament we just had
yes thank you thought I think you said
it was yes it was time for new it was
necessary like it might be necessary to
go to the dentist yes it's personal
attacks and yeah I think it was quite
strange for me because I believe like
the election campaign very much started
on bricks
that was its main theme but all of a
sudden I feel as though it's changed
Breck's it's getting pushed a bit
further back now and young people are
starting to look at their policies it's
not a good thing me personally no
because the whole this election needs to
be on brexit because that's the biggest
thing that's facing our country at the
moment and I feel that's what people
should be voting for who we think is
going to get this fruit so there are
things happening in Telford alone that
are far far more important than brexit I
mean does anybody even know what brexit
stands for so Gerry but I picked up
there is anger irritation
disillusionment with politicians and
also a bit of a battle really about is
it about brexit or is it about other
things obviously Boris Johnson needs it
to be about brexit jeremy corbyn needs
all these people there to think it's
about the NHS or public services right
as much as they want to have interesting
discussions about characters about
personalities fundamentally it does come
down to breakfast okay well we talked to
them about brexit don't we so let's see
what they thought about it sorry but
it's all about breaks it and anything
else is a sideshow yeah once once
there's been a decision about leaving or
staying in the EU then everything else
will follow on it doesn't matter what
they promise about rail water NHS
whatever nothing will happen until a
decision is made we didn't know what it
entailed what it was gonna happen the
the effects of it that will end make
people feel like you know what we want
we've been told whether it was truth or
not truth and that will then future
opinions of the politicians will change
according to that I think do you think
the Conservatives can both get brexit
done and unleash Britain's potential no
I don't think they can because if they
could have done it it would have been
done by now you can't go in and say okay
this is what we want and then they you
turn and say well no
and that's okay so to go off come back
with exactly the same paper and say okay
look look here we go and then uh that's
what you've just brought us there's
nothing been changed new what we years
ago I believe know the fellow England's
going through bricks in this it's
everywhere any whenever you go on
holiday you hear it from other people
it's just like it's quite sad to be seen
like that the minute
well there's brexit fatigue there isn't
there and brexit frustration bar did you
get a sense that there might be labor
voters there that might lend boris
johnson a vote because they want to
quote get brexit done most definitely
and that fatigue I think definitely
plays into Boris Johnson's hands people
are sick of hearing about brexit
strangely they love talking about brexit
but they're sick of hearing about breaks
it but I think at the same time that
breaks of fatigue will will work for him
people just want a resolution to breaks
it so they they want brexit and
resolution but jeremy corbyn's
predicating his success on the fact that
voters think the elections about other
things other than for exes so what did
they think about jeremy corbyn in labor
I do believe Jeremy Corbyn has come out
only ever so slightly above Boris
Johnson in terms of in terms of he seems
more honest in what he's saying so long
as he's not against Boris Johnson in a
in the same room having debate with each
other then he's more honest if he's by
himself
I'm watching different interviews with
him he he doesn't seem to have as
somebody other politicians answers to
all the questions but other questions he
just seems to he'll never give a
straight answer
it's almost as ovals are innovate and
move on to another to another question
I'm just going with who I feel is is is
more at the moment honest and a nice
person which is Jeremy Corbyn at the
moment wherever I'm right without or not
but I don't know if that's what I
believe at the moment yeah
how would you describe the current labor
party what it stands for good
old-fashioned seven to socialism no
pretty scary really not very much feels
like a step backwards I think he's doing
a good job at standing for the working
class yes more about the people thinking
about what people really were they
concerned for the people like waiting
for some a student like we're doing for
the students like therefore you like the
unit ease off it's an incentive for more
people to like for more students to go
to uni they clearly want to redistribute
wealth in some way but some of the 130
ideas they've come up with not
particularly happy with for instance
wanting to tax people with second houses
that might have bought them as a pension
plan rather than invest in a pension
Jerry I was a bit surprised by what they
said about Jeremy Corbyn because he
started out being deeply deeply
unpopular but there has been a bit of an
uptick in his polling and is it a case
of the more people see of him they like
him a little bit more it is all relative
of course we've seen just today a large
uptick in terms of jeremy corbyn's net
favorability so that is borne out that
does suggest that the longer this
campaign goes on the sick of people get
a borås and the more they like jeremy
corbyn well let's happen listen to what
they had to say about Boris Johnson the
Conservatives to think he's gotten
self-control himself by telling lies and
things and people are turning away from
that I mean like when he went to the
Queen with all that saying he had the
permission people are like then you know
he's supposed to be born in our country
and when he's telling lies it didn't
doesn't it trust him if it was still
Theresa May in his place yeah I would
trust I feel as though I would trust her
more than I do Boris Johnson it's just
him and it's his antics
when he gets up to the way he's shot in
motion even when she was leaving sort of
thing in like with him there is no
emotion there's no there's nothing if
the election goes is why he will have
more people who will go along with the
brexit note who will say yes because I
have a majority so he's saying that he's
only an effective leader when he's got a
gun of yes-men backing him up well
aren't they well apparently not because
they didn't vote for the bread city in
fact using a triumph of parliamentary
democracy that the Parliament blocks
doing the silly thing no it's not a
triumph because the majority of people
might be in a small majority but the
majority of people voted to leave but
just in terms what the Conservative
Party stands for does it stand for
business the union workers no more
business division finished answer
probably the opposite of what I said
about the Labour Party yeah and you said
middle-class does it stand for the
middle class yeah yeah just stand for
more than anything I did like I did like
the Conservative Party marginally bigger
but to be honest I think I think that
much of a muchness in what they what
they say whether we can believe them
Gerry that just reaffirms the idea that
Boris Johnson has huge trust issues with
the voters and perhaps they are throwing
a dice and taking a risk on him because
they won't brexit we assumed at the
start the campaign that Boris Johnson
was was an electoral asset that doesn't
seem to be the case for a lot of people
who emotionally and politically are
aligned to labour a lot of whom will be
voting conservative because of brexit
but the more they hear and see of Boris
Johnson the less inclined they are to do
that I think it would be really great if
when you're watching when I'm watching
Parliament on TV which I do quite often
that they would stop brain like donkeys
at each other
and actually get together and say right
we're all here and we're all paid to do
a job let's get on pull together and get
things sorted the voters in this room
just a tiny piece of the bigger
electoral picture but swing voters like
them will decide the selection in
marginal seats in just a few days time
battery B Sky News